mes amis mes amis mes amis mes amis je
viens d'avoir au téléphone notre grand
leader thierry ardisson oui ne vous
réjouissez pas trop vite il est tombé en
panne de voiture dans le bois de
boulogne où il s'était rendu pour des
raisons professionnelles je répète pour
des raisons strictement professionnel
thierry ne pourra donc être là ce soir
avec nous en direct au studio bonaparte
et nous allons faire l'émission en
duplex téléphonique
il ya juste un petit problème il faut
que les téléspectateurs ne se doute de
rien c'est pourquoi je vais vous
demander d'afficher sur vos visages soit
un sourire niais soit une moue innocente
soit encore pour les plus doués d'entre
vous un rictus angélique le
téléspectateur moyen comme vous le savez
est idiot et il se laissera berné comme
un enfant
par ce stratagème génial voilà d'ores et
déjà pour vous détendre je vous ai
composé un petit bout rim et qui je
crois résume assez bien la situation
ne laissons pas paraître notre désarroi
pour ne pas compromettre notre déjà roi
[Rires]
avec danièle gilbert
le professeur rollin le président flora
le chien de témoin alors professeur oui
thierry oui mais je fais mon bon soir
ici on voit la fête votre bon soir
normalement diri puisque tout est normal
hein pas vrai les amis messieurs bonsoir
bienvenue au studio mena pas bon hardy
matt avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet
je voudrais vous dire que comme toute
émission qui se respecte
nous allons vous offrir des cadeaux des
tas de cadeaux
ce soir vous allez vous partager son
téléviseur type sayad et les commandes
vocales
pour gagner il suffit d'appeler le 47 28
02 47 pour élire votre télépathie jeux
préférés parmi les cadres que nous
allons vous présenter tout au long de
l'émission les 100 premiers iront donc
un téléviseur tsai athénée commandes
vocales
les 1000 suivants recevront la cachette
du mal cavic de spike lee qui sort cette
semaine sur nos écrans ses séquelles
film qui sort cette semaine thierry
balkanique
[Applaudissements]
alors professeur et bien à thierry comme
il est désormais de tradition un petit
bilan de la semaine dernière la séquence
qui a le mieux marché et la semaine
dernière c'était la séquence jesse
jackson et ça c'était votre ip et la
tyrie vraiment en six émissions 6 idée
géniale vraiment on peut dire que vous
êtes ce qu'on appelle un magicien de la
télévision mais cette semaine tout
magicien que vous êtes j'ai bien peur
que vous ne parveniez pas à trouver une
idée du même tonneau
t'es trompé rentrer à j'ai trouvé j'ai
trouvé j'ai trouvé là je me suis dit
est-ce que janet jackson n'aurait pas
bon thierry mais comment vous est venue
cette idée géniale
j'étais au restaurant avec ma femme et
un seul coup en regardant ma femme il un
pasteur mais qui a un frère je me suis
dit c'est janet jackson n'est pas comme
ça que j'ai trouvés près des îles vous
mangiez quoi ces indiscrétions et 4
l'état ni aux professeurs dont le tir
est génial et avant de continuer votre
émission
je voudrais vous dire un petit bout de
savon particuliers et des chiens devient
cette année on va écouter que thierry
dol et attendent attendent et a détalé
vraiment ça ne va bras on vous entend
trop mal les téléspectateurs vont se
douter de quelque chose il serait
préférable que vous veniez nous
rejoindre en studio 1
je serai pas l'avant avant dix minutes
un quart d'heure moi on va meubler
thierry foncé foncé pour ben j'y arrive
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais 1
pouces bleus